>> Thank you.
>> You have been listening to
authorities for Michigan state
university, law enforcement
they are reporting that the
threat is over.
The suspect, they say, is
responsible for killing three
people on campus several hours
ago, and injuring five others.
That suspect, they say, took
his own life.
They say that threat is over.
The shelter in place order that
had been FX in msu, that has
been lifted.
So, that will be a relief to
that community there.
The tragedy, however, still
remains.
Three people killed.
And different locations, to at
one location in Berkey hall,
one at a nearby location at the
student union.
Three fatalities in total right
now, five others injured,
transported to a local
hospital.
Some of them are now with
life-threatening conditions.
But then you as you heard
moments ago, this all develops
so quickly.
The threat is over.
The suspect, they say, for whom
they receive photos, just about
an hour and a half ago, that
suspect died in an encounter
with police where he took his
own life.
My panel of experts and
analysts back here now with me.
Shimon prokupecz, Andrew Mccabe,
Shawn turner, John Miller,
Juliette kayyem, thank you all
for being here.
John, you are the first to
alert us to this encounter,
which happened not even one
hour ago, just a few minutes
before midnight, you heard the
authorities from Michigan state
university tell us that the
suspect were dead.
Any details around the margins
for how this encounter took
place?
>> It was after the clear
description went out.
But more importantly, after the
photographs went out to all of
the police that weren't
saturating that area, beyond
those who were on campus, and
then driving down that street
Michigan state police
encountered a man wearing a
jacket that was likely the
jacket in the photo, the pants
that was likely the pants in
the photo, the backpack.
And they then initiated a
pedestrian stop.
And as they approached, the
Twitchell pulled out a weapon,
shot himself, took his own
life.
And then, they recovered
evidence at the scene,
including the gun he used to
shoot himself, and and it
national gun in the backpack,
magazines, and additional
ammunition.
That tells us a lot.
That tells us that this
individual came prepared.
He came prepared with multiple
weapons and a large amount of
ammunition to commit tremendous
damage, which he did.
So, as on campus, the fear ebbs
into sorrow for those who are
wounded and lost.
But also, drama for the
students who have gone through
this tonight on lockdown,
hiding in closets, under desks
in classrooms.
We still have a lot of
questions about the individual
behind this shooting.
Now that they have taken him
into custody, now that he has
taken his own life, that gives
them a chance to go through
that material.
Does he have I.D.?
Can they establish an
association or a relationship
with the school?
Was he a student?
Was he a former student?
With the ever an employee?
Does he have a relationship
with somebody at the school?
All of those are gonna be open
questions that will help them
go towards what was the motive
before, for this horrific event?
I will tell you this, John, and
you know this, from your own
experience.
What you find out what the
motive is behind these
shootings, if you find out,
they never really add up to
something that would make
sense.
Given the carnage and the cost
of these actions.
And because the individual is
now dead, learning that motive
may not be a parent.
It may be, when they get the
search warrant for the house,
when they go through the
computers when they are able to
enter his phone, and look for
that reason.
But again, this investigation
now is defined, to find answers,
not to move towards a
prosecution.
>> Again, we don't know --
>> This one individual.
>> We don't know the identity
of the suspect.
We do not know the suspect is
connected with any way with the
Michigan state university.
We do know, as you say, when
they do find a motive.
We know it won't make sense
because by definition, its mask
like this makes no sense.
It can't make sense.
Shimon prokupecz, just very
quickly, when you hear deaths
in multiple locations, it gives
you a sense of truly how
terrifying this must have been,
three and a half hours of
terror, and what will now be
days, months, you know, years
of mourning.
>> Right, and we also don't
know.
Some of the stuff that is kind
of going through my head right
now, listening to police their
top, we don't know why he
stopped, right?
We don't know what happened.
So, he gets into the union all,
what happens there?
We know there was a victim
there, why did he stop
--
and you can just walk in.
So, did he know where he was
going?
And was he targeting certain
locations?
Because he seemed to move
through the area.
So, that is certainly something
that I think is going to be
important for a law
enforcement.
Because also someone asked
wisely, was there any
affiliation to the school?
And that's gonna be the key
thing right now for authorities,
certainly to figure out that.
>> We just don't know.
Sean turner, national security
analyst and teacher at Michigan
state university.
I imagine some sense of relief
at this point.
>> Yes, John, when we consider
the tragedy that the shooter
brought to our campus tonight,
it's really hard to see any
positive and, in the outcome
here.
I will tell you that I have
been in touch with colleagues
all over campus, and there is a
sense of relief that this
shooter has been neutralized,
and that our students, faculty,
and staff are all safe.
But as everyone has said, now
comes all the questions.
Why did this individual come on
to our campus?
And why did he kill people and
wreaked the havoc that they've
reached?
What was the motive?
So, we're gonna turn to that
now, but the really important
thing for us is that everyone
is safe.
And, you know, tomorrow, you
know, we are gonna look to
understand the cause of
factors.
You know, I have been, I just
wanna give you a sense, John,
of this community.
I have been in touch with
professors this evening.
It's almost 1 am in the
morning.
And they are still reaching out
to the students to make sure
that they are okay.
It just gives you a sense of
what this community is.
>> And they're gonna need it
either.
You are all gonna need each
other in the coming days.
Andrew Mccabe and Juliette
kayyem, 30 seconds to each of
you.
Andy, just first, what now?
What's going on right now?
>> Sure, John.
So, the FBI and their
colleagues are going through
the history of this person to
try to understand what his
motivations were, to try to
understand what brought him to
this moment in this community,
and at this time.
You know, Michigan state, this
community is struggling to
understand why they are the
latest in what is a uniquely
American experience, and
understanding and experiencing
a mass shooting.
But it is the job for lot
Forsman to understand, as much
as they can, about what brought
this person to this moment and
this mass shooting tonight and
we will hear more about that I
think in the future.
>> And, Juliet, again, we have
about 30 seconds left.
And as this community mourns,
you know, what was learned here,
do you think?
>> Yes, that's gonna be a huge
part of it.
We are all rightfully
applauding the transparency of
the police department, what
they know, what they did not
know that the basing, how
quickly they came out, telling
us when they are next gonna
come out.
We know there is another press
conference next hour.
So, what's happening back on
campuses's shelter, and as I've
been saying to these kids, a
lot of them have been out in
the cold.
They ran out.
They want to get them
comfortable as much as they
can.
And potentially, they are there
are identified victims --
and there are also a lot of
parents who by all accounts I'm
talking to are standing outside
the university.
They want to see their kids.
They should see their kids.
So, you're gonna see a lot of
family unification.
Maybe kids leaving campus for a
couple of days while it's close
to go home.
So where the kids are from.
That is essentially --
the school is going to be very
active for the next couple of
hours.
>> Yes, very active for the
next couple of hours.